Where are we?
We are on problem 15.
Let's see.
They have a bunch of
triangles drawn.
So let me get the line tool and
see what I can do about
drawing these.
I've got a big triangle, looks
something like that.
It's the big triangle, and
there's this altitude to that
drops down like that.
And there's a smaller triangle
within it that looks
something like this.
A smaller triangle and then
this is a 90 degree angle
right here.
It's perpendicular.
q, s, p, v.
Oh my God no, I messed up.
I should have done this
ahead of time.
I'm wasting your time.
Bear with me, I drew
this line wrong.
This line is something
different.
That line looks like this.
All right, now I'm
back in business.
t and then r.
It took me almost two minutes
just to draw this thing.
And it says, note, figure
not drawn to scale.
It says, in triangle
pqr above, qs over
qv is equal to 1/3.
And it says, pt over
pr is equal to 3/4.
What is the value
of the fraction?
And they want to know area of
triangle pst over area of
triangle pqr?
Now let's see what we can do.
I haven't been thinking
just yet.
I've just been drawing
and writing.
So they say, qs over qv, over
this whole thing, is 1/3.
Fair enough.
And they say, pt over
pr is equal to 3/4.
OK.
Fair enough.
So, area of pst over
area of pqr.
So what's the area of pst?
That would be just the base
times the height times 1/2.
And we'll see the 1/2's cancel
out, we don't have to do them,
but I'll do it just
to figure it out.
So it's 1/2 pt times sv.
And then area of pqr
is going to be 1/2.
So it's this whole thing,
pr times qv.
So the area of this triangle pst
over the area of triangle
pqr is just going to be 1/2 pt
times sv over 1/2 times the
area of pqr.
So it's over this.
1/2 pr times qv.
Let's see what we could
figure out.
We definitely see the
1/2's cancel out.
Do we know what pt over pr is?
Let me see, pt over pr.
They give it right here.
pt over pr is 3/4.
So this term is equal to 3/4.
So this is equal to 3/4
times sv over qv.
And now we're at a conundrum.
We know what qv is.
But we only know qs,
we don't know sv.
Let me ask you a question.
If qs over qv, over this whole
thing, is 1/3-- so this pink
distance right here is 1/3 of
this entire length, right?
Because this distance over the
entire distance is 1/3.
Then sv over qv so then this
is going to be 2/3.
If this is 1/3, this'll
be 2/3.
So then we know that sv
over the whole thing
is going to be 2/3.
So this is 2/3.
And then 3/4 times 2/3,
well the 3's cancel
out, and you get 2/4.
It equals 1/2, and you
just fill it in.
Next problem.
Hope you get that.
Most of it we just figured out
what the areas were and just
substituted.
And then we just have to figure
out what sv over qv is,
given qs over qv.
We figured out that
sv over qv is 2/3.
I hope I did not confuse you.
It's Thanksgiving and it's not
a good day to confuse people.
OK number 16.
Let the function h be defined by
h of x is equal to 14 plus
x squared over 4.
If h of 2m is equal
to 9m, what is one
possible value of m?
Well let's just figure
out what h of 2m is.
So h of 2m is equal to, just
using this definition of its
function, 14 plus-- we're taking
h of 2m, so it's 2m
squared over 4.
And we also know that
this is equal to 9m.
And let's see what we can
do to simplify it.
So we could say 14 plus
4m squared over 4.
Just squaring both of these.
This is equal to 9.
This cancels out.
Oh, that was equal to 9m.
Sorry.
And now we're left with 14 plus
m squared is equal to 9m.
We're left with a quadratic.
It might not be obvious
to you.
Let's subtract 9m from
both sides and
rearrange a little bit.
You get m squared minus 9m
plus 14 is equal to 0.
All I did is I took this 9m,
put it on this side,
subtracted 9m from both
sides, and put the
m squared out front.
Now we have a quadratic and we
need to solve-- figure out
where this expression intersects
the x-axis, or
figure out the roots
of this quadratic.
And we can factor this.
If you remember your factoring
from later Algebra I or some
Algebra II.
This would be m minus 7 times
m minus 2 is equal to 0.
And how did I figure that out?
Well I had to figure out two
numbers that when I multiply
them, equals positive 14, and
that when I add them, is equal
to negative 9.
So 7 times 2 is 14, or
negative 7 times
negative 2 is also 14.
And we know it's negative
because it has to go to
negative 9.
And that's just a review
of what you
learned in algebra class.
If this was confusing,
you might
want to review factoring.
Anyway, m minus 7 times m
minus 2 is equal to 0.
That means that m is
equal to 7 or 2.
And you can fill in either one
of those, because they say
what is one possible
value for m?
I have a minute left, so and I
only have two problems left.
Well, that's good for one extra
video, so I'll see you
in the next video.